of commerce gina raimondo for a look at
the massive
economic opportunity of the new energy
economy with help from speakers
representing the private sector
and civil society secretary raimondo
thank you jennifer good morning
everybody uh
like jennifer i'm a former governor of
the state of rhode island
and i am president biden's commerce
secretary
and as uh secretary granholm
said we all are tired
of the old view that we have to make a
trade-off
between jobs and
the environment meeting the needs of
climate and the economy
and so as the commerce secretary i am
joining forces uh with all of you
to show leadership uh
in our commercial sector as
we look to the private sector for
innovations
as we've all been talking about and new
technologies that are necessary
in order for us to continue to move
forward in our fight against climate
change
it's been amazing to listen to
what is happening all around the world
and it is thrilling to be
here on president biden's team
to be leading again with all of you
in the world on this climate uh
raising our innovation ambition is going
to be what makes it
possible to raise the world's climate
ambition
and that is what today is all about and
government cannot do it alone we need
the private sector
we need private sector innovation we
need entrepreneurialism
and we need academic research and
academic research institutions to play a
huge
role in uncovering and developing new
technologies and innovations
investments that can unlock massive
economic opportunities as well
already in 2020 global investments in
clean technologies
cross the 500 billion dollar mark
and in the coming decades the new energy
economy will open
multi trillion dollar markets for clean
technologies
especially driven by fast-growing
emerging economies
as many of you have said this is a
once-in-a-generation opportunity to
develop
and produce advanced technologies
export them around the world and speed
global net zero transitions
which will ultimately as many of you
have said
lead to the creation of millions of jobs
millions of good high-paying union jobs
so it is my great pleasure this morning
to introduce a series of academic and
private sector innovators
who will be necessary to allow all of us
to achieve our goals
first i would like to introduce dr fatih
beral
executive director of the international
energy agency
to frame the climate challenge and the
central role of innovation in reaching
net zero emissions
dr burrell's leadership has led a
transformation
and modernization of the international
energy agency
to become the global hub for
collaboration
on clean energy transitions he chairs
the world
economic forum's davos energy advisory
board
and is widely recognized as a top global
leader
on the world's energy scene so please
join me in welcoming dr bural
distinguished guests i would like to
commend president biden
for convening this summit within 100
days of taking office
and i welcome to commitments to reduce
emissions
announced by so many countries
it is clear that the level of commitment
to fight climate change has
never been higher this is excellent news
but i will be blunt
commitments alone are not enough
we need real change in the real world
right now the data does not match
the rhetoric and the gap is getting
wider and wider our
latest estimates for global emissions in
2021
this year are a warning for
humanity emissions are on track
for their second largest increase in the
history
we are not recovering from covet in a
sustainable way
and we remain on a path of dangerous
levels of global warming yet
there are grants for optimism
electricity generated from renewables
solar wind and others will break
records this year and the sales of
electric cars
will reach another record high
but getting to net zero emissions
requires much more than that
we will need to transform our entire
energy system
this means drastically cutting emissions
from
trucks ships and planes
we will also need to do the same for
steel and cement factories
chemical plants and in farming
we have today many technologies
at our disposal energy efficiency
solar wind electric cars nuclear power
and many more and
we need to deploy these as quickly as
possible
however ie analysis
shows that about half the reductions
to get to net zero emissions in 2050
will need to come from technologies that
are not
yet ready for market today
this calls for massive leaps in
innovation
innovation across batteries hydrogen
synthetic fuels carbon capture and many
other technologies on 18th of may
only a few weeks from now the
international energy agency
will release a roadmap for
how the global energy sector can reach
net zero by 2050. make no mistake
this is a herculean task
participants to this summit have used
the occasion
to make new announcements let me add
one from the iea according to our
upcoming roadmap reaching net syria will
triple clean energy investment
opportunities
over the next decade this will generate
millions of well-paid jobs and create
the industries of the future but
our priority is to make sure these
benefits reach as many people as
possible
ladies and gentlemen we need to work all
together
to achieve our goals and create a better
future
for all of us
it is you remind us all of the urgency
with which we must do this work and it
is a stunning statistic
really to think that 45
of the emissions reduction we need to
achieve must come from technologies
which aren't fully developed today
so it's a really a call to action for
all of
us and the innovators in our country to
continue to push
as it relates to new technology and
innovation
next it is my great pleasure to welcome
dr shirlean
jackson president of rensselaer
polytechnic
institute one of our country's
leading research universities dr jackson
a particle physicist
has served as the chair of the nuclear
regulatory commission
and as a top scientific advisor to
president obama
who awarded her the national medal of
science
she serves on the board of the nature
conservancy and has had a truly
extraordinarily distinguished career
so please join me in welcoming dr
jackson
thank you madam secretary it is a great
honor to contribute to this summit
universities such as rensselaer
polytechnic institute
are crucial in developing and incubating
the new technologies required
for a net zero world nature
has had billions of years to perfect the
conversion of light
into usable energy at rensselaer we are
re-imagining photosynthesis
building on advances at the intersection
of biotechnology
and materials science to develop
engineered photo systems
we envision using lipid nanoparticles
such as those used today to stabilize
mrna for vaccines as a matrix for
biomimetic components able to generate
hydrogen or capture electrons for
electricity
or fix atmospheric co2 for the
production of
carbon neutral fuels and chemicals
in energy storage our researchers are
looking
beyond lithium to the use of more earth
abundant materials
such as magnesium potassium calcium or
sodium
and using novel self-healing electrode
designs
to develop low-cost safe energy-dense
sustainable batteries however
there is no innovation without
innovators
universities play the crucial role in
educating the next generation of talent
to address the challenges of creating a
clean energy economy
the united states and other nations must
draw upon
and develop the complete global talent
pool
including women and minority groups
historically underrepresented
in science and engineering universities
are the crossroads
for collaboration across disciplines
sectors
geographies and generations and an
integrative approach is required to
decarbonize the many
interconnected systems of our daily
lives
therefore i am very pleased to announce
that rensselaer polytechnic institute is
launching
the institute for energy the built
environment
and smart systems in partnership with
siemens
lutron electronics the international
architecture firms hks
and perkins and will and the brooklyn
law school
the new institute based in new york city
will use the most advanced
digital technologies to drive
decarbonization of urban
environments at the systems level it
will model
integrated transportation communications
and supply
chain networks it will link
architectural design
engineering and a new approach to
regulation to create infrastructure
that is both net zero and climate
resilient
it will use new materials renewable
energy systems
and sentient building platforms to
maximize
human health and well-being we thank
president biden for convening this
summit
and we look forward to the work ahead
i'm your new institute that's amazing
it's exactly the kind of research that's
going to move this work forward
and we're thrilled that you were making
this announcement at president biden's
summit this week it's
fantastic and thank you for being with
us so now we're going to hear
from some leaders focused on
decarbonizing specific
sectors of the economy starting with
renewable energy for the electricity
sector
i'm very pleased to welcome dr danielle
murfield who's with us this morning
she is the chief technology officer of
ge renewable energy
which is of course a leading us company
that invests in the next generation of
clean
technologies and obviously creates many
jobs in the process of the
of doing that work danielle is a member
of the national academy of engineering
dr murfield leads research and
development at ge
into exciting clean energy technologies
such as offshore wind and
energy storage and on a personal level
when i was the governor of bird island
rhode island was home to
america's first offshore wind farm
and we had the great pleasure of working
with ge
in doing that so please join me in
welcoming dr murfield
i'd like to start by thanking the biden
administration for convening this
important summit
for its commitment to decarbonizing our
energy sector and for its strong support
for innovation
the administration's right to focus on
innovation as a key part of the solution
to address
climate change from our founding
innovation has been the lifeblood of ge
that history of innovation led us to
develop technology that delivers
one-third of the world's electricity
today
innovation is key to our shared success
so we invest
one and a half billion dollars annually
in energy related r d
including at our global research center
in upstate new york which is focused on
breakthrough technologies
and across ge we appreciate that success
requires partnership
we're proud to collaborate with the
department of energy our national labs
and universities across the country
to support innovation for the energy
sector innovation in power generation
and grid operation is enabling solutions
to lower greenhouse gas emissions
and secure a path to a low carbon future
one example is ge's hollyard x
the world's most powerful offshore wind
turbine in operation today
just one rotation of its blades can
power a home for two days
it will power the world's largest
offshore wind farm in the uk
and some of the first big offshore
projects here in the u.s
including vineyard wind which has
already benefited from the improved
permitting process
under this administration the hollyoad x
is complemented by our global
onshore wind development efforts where
we've driven innovation for the u.s
market as the largest supplier of
onshore wind turbines in the country
we've commercialized new digital
technology to optimize performance
and even coupled renewable energy farms
with energy storage
to supply power when it's most needed
we're also pursuing innovative
breakthroughs for the future
this includes partnering with the
department of energy to pioneer
manufacturing techniques such as 3d
printing of wind blades and towers to
reduce
logistics and materials costs as well as
developing superconducting generators
for offshore wind
that will help us generate even more
power offshore
and unlike conventional generators these
don't require rare earth materials
helping secure our energy supply chain
beyond generation we're also working on
innovative solutions for digitizing and
modernizing the grid
to ensure reliable delivery of
electricity with improved security
and lower operational costs we know that
for innovation to succeed
we must promote diversity in our
thinking and ensure we tap the thoughts
of many communities
to that end the ge foundation our
independent charitable organization
is announcing a commitment of up to 100
million dollars
to increase the diversity of young
people in engineering
this program will provide
underrepresented students hands-on
exposure
to engineering concepts and careers and
ultimately award scholarships
developing the next generation of
engineers focused on building a world
that works
we look forward to partnering with the
countries and customers represented here
at the summit
to support the energy transition and
transform our global energy sector
together
thank you thank you and thank you to ge
for your leadership it is
um exciting to
both innovate create jobs meet the needs
of climate change
and move towards a more equitable
workforce by providing
opportunities for a diverse workforce so
thank you
in addition to producing renewable
energy a net zero transition will
require
transporting that power and using it
across the economy as we've heard from
many of the world leaders this morning
will need to start building smart
electrified systems
all over the world so i would now like
to
introduce audrey zeidelman who is from
uh alphabet's moonshot factory audrey
and her colleagues know a thing or two
about this she spent over three decades
leading organizations with the goal of
making power
cleaner more affordable and
more reliable she was most recently the
ceo
of the australian energy market operator
and while in australia
audrey was a founding member of the
global power system
consortium she also previously was the
chair
of the new york public service
commission where she oversaw the
electric gas
water steam and communications utilities
in new york not an easy job welcome
audrey
thank you president biden special envoy
kerry
secretary armando secretary granholm and
honored guests
it's an honor to be here today as we all
know
to achieve our carbon reduction targets
we must provide people worldwide
with access to clean affordable and
reliable
electricity as a 30-year veteran of the
electric industry
today i'd like to talk about the vital
role technology innovation
and broad sector collaboration must have
in achieving this goal
what most people don't understand is
that the power system
only works if the supply of electricity
being used
every moment of the day this has always
been a difficult
engineering challenge but it's becoming
even more so
as we decarbonize the grid
i have firsthand experience of this and
of how climate change is only making
this task harder
just over a year ago i was in the
control room with my team
working to keep the lights on during
unprecedented bushfires
we were losing major parts of the system
the limitations on our modeling and
visualization tools meant we had to act
with
incomplete information because it was
all they had
our engineers relied on experience
rather than
accurate data to make critical decisions
we were successful however as we know
from recent events in texas
and in california this is not always the
case
the greatest fear of an operator is the
inability to keep the power on
especially when our communities are most
vulnerable
it is possible to run reliable power
systems on renewables
but we urgently need smarter investments
and better software to make it work
that's why last year australia and other
leading system operators
formed the global power system
transformation consortium
or the gpst the gpst
is designed to direct and combine
research efforts
and to share our learnings worldwide
especially with developing nations
i'm honored to formally announce today
that the united states
and the united kingdom are joining the
gpst
and grateful that u.s secretary of
energy grand home
and uk beis secretary of state cortang
helped us launch the gpst consortium
formally
i believe so strongly in the importance
of integrating cutting-edge technology
into grid design and management i left
the energy industry to join x
alphabet's moonshot factory to lead
their moonshot for the electric grid
and be a part of alphabet's
industry-leading work to combat
climate change and build a greener
economy
our team has been working with partners
to develop the tools required to move
our grids
out of the industrial age and into the
age of intelligence
i look forward to working with gps team
members
governments and industry leaders to make
the moonshot
of a clean affordable and reliable
electricity system
worldwide a reality thank you
thank you audrey thank you for that
terrific presentation and your exciting
announcement about gpst
and thank you for reminding us of the
very real
and dangerous consequences of not uh not
doing this work and not innovating with
urgency
so last but absolutely not least it is
my great pleasure to introduce
anna borg who has a long and
distinguished career
in the energy sector anna is the
president
and ceo of battenfall a swedish
multinational power company which has
been a leading innovator
in using green hydrogen to decarbonize
highly emitting industrial processes
prior to that she was the cfo of this
company and as i said has a long and
distinguished career in the energy
sector
welcome anna
thank you secretary for the nice
introduction
thank you president biden and secretary
kerry for your leadership
with the united states now re-entering
the global climate arena
and the paris agreement you can count on
sweden as a partner
in this critical work it is encouraging
to hear that
united states is now joining the lead it
initiative
watanval is one of the largest energy
companies in europe with its origin and
base in sweden
a few years ago watenfall embarked on a
journey
with the goal to enable fossil free
living within one generation
this is not our sustainability strategy
it's our business
strategy and it is sustainable
we are not just phasing out fossil
emissions from our own operations
we are working in close partnerships
with our customers to help them do the
same
we have more than 100 years of
experience of innovation and a large and
growing portfolio of sustainable and
fossil free electricity
we believe we can drive innovation
through electrification
five years ago building on the swedish
heritage of cross industry innovation
we began a partnership with leading
mining and steel companies
lkab and ssab together
we created hybrid with the aim of
producing the world's
first fossil free steel the key is to
replace the coal used in the existing
steel making process
with hydrogen produced using fossil free
electricity
this is the biggest shift in steel
making industry
in 1 000 years together we have built a
pilot plant in the swedish town of lulio
and this year it will produce the
world's first fossil-free steel
right now we are taking the next step a
demonstration plant for large-scale
production of iron sponge
this is no longer a vision it's
happening and it has the potential
to change the world hybrid is not the
only initiative emerging from sweden
there is a growing industry cluster
around mining steel
and new energy intense businesses like
battery production for electric cars
one of the main problems now is finding
all the people needed to work
in these industries and projects the
current technology development is
dramatically driving costs down for co2
free technologies
the single most effective tool in this
transformation in europe
is the fact that there is a price for
emitting co2
this drives innovation button file is
partnering up to decarbonize also other
sectors like refineries
transportation mining and chemical
industry
i commit to make sure that vatemphal
meets the targets in the paris agreement
by phasing out fossil emissions from our
operations
and by enabling our customers to do the
same
transforming into sustainable business
is not only possible
it is the way to have a competitive edge
in the future and the future
is not happening in 2050 all of us are
creating it
here and now thank you
thank you thank you on a button fall is
doing amazing work
the thought of producing uh steel
without reliance at all on fossil fuel
is very exciting and it's just one of
the many innovations
that your company and other companies
are
moving on so that concludes the portion
of this panel
for the non-governmental speakers i will
simply
uh thank you all for participating thank
you
for your work and again i think that
what we just
heard from the from the private sector
is how important it is for this
um to be a
public private nonprofit partnership the
entire
way through if we are going to do the
work that is required
so thank you all and with that i will
turn it back over to
secretary granholm
actually i think we're turning it back
over to secretary kerry
thank you thank you for a rapid turnover
uh
gina thank you so much for uh your
stewardship and uh
jennifer likewise uh you both brought
special energy no pun intended uh
to this session and we're deeply
appreciative for it
um in a few moments president biden is
going to
rejoin and he will lead the last
session and be here throughout it
as we hear about the extraordinary
possibilities of the new economy
but let me just say very very quickly uh
about the
session we just heard i've been at this
for a while
and i've sat and listened to people in
many different venues but i have to tell
you this was exciting
this was energizing it was incredible to
listen
to what the leaders of uh of kenya
israel norway uae singapore
uh denmark were telling us is happening
now
and what was fascinating about that is
that each of those countries
are smaller than the 20 that are
providing 81
of all the emissions so if ever there
was an
underscoring of the challenge that we
face here there are
exciting things happening unbelievable
things happening
but as dr burel reminded us
uh as a as a as a as a community of
nations writ large
we are not getting the job done and what
president biden
decided when he determined to have this
this this
uh summit was the key must be the
raising of ambition
country after country has stepped up but
the test is going to be uh not in the
rhetoric
as dr bureau said it's going to be in
whether or not we really
buckle down and get this done uh it's
not a lack of capacity
it's it's an apparent lack of willpower
in some places
to move as fast as we are able to move
the the bright future that awaits us on
the other side of this transition
is what president biden wants to focus
on as the last session
of of this uh gathering so
without further ado we want to get to
that uh i thank everybody for
taking part in in this particular
session
and in a moment we're going to listen to
the economic benefits and jobs
the once in a generation opportunity
that we have
to transition our economies and to do
better for our people
as well as for the planet
itself so we look forward to that
session thank you
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to
[Music]
audio check one two audio check one two
three four
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
well welcome back and thank you all
again
all the world leaders who've joined us
thank you for joining in john thank you
for putting this together
we've made great progress in my view so
far
i'm grateful to all the leaders who have
announced new commitments
to help us meet the existential threat
of climate change
this summit is a start a start of a road
that will take us to glasgow
for the u.n climate change conference in
november where we're going to make
these commitments real putting all of
our nations on a path to a secure
prosperous and sustainable future
today's final session is not about
the threat of climate change poses it's
about the opportunity
that addressing climate change provides
it's an opportunity to create millions
of good paying jobs around the world
and innovate and innovative sectors you
know
jobs that bring greater quality of life
greater dignity to people
performing those jobs in every nation
for a line worker electricians utility
workers
line transmission lines connecting
battery storage
and making our electric grid more modern
for automotive workers
building electric cars trucks and buses
skilled workers installing and
charging stations to accommodate them
throughout our countries
construction workers engineers
insulators upgrading our schools and
commercial buildings and
constructing new energy efficient homes
manufacturing manufacturing workers
building nuclear and carbon capture
technologies solar panels and wind
turbines
and people working in the fields that we
haven't even conceived of yet
on forms on farms and on factories and
in laboratories and universities
but things we haven't even thought of so
far this is this challenge
and these opportunities are going to be
met by working people in
every nation and as we transition
to a clean energy future we must ensure
that workers who have thrived in
yesterday's
and today's industries have as bright as
tomorrow
in the new industries as well as in the
places where they live
in the communities they have built when
we invest in climate resilience
and infrastructure we create
opportunities for everyone
that that's a the heart of my jobs plan
that i propose here in the united states
it's how our nation intends to build an
economy that gives
everybody a fair shot as you heard in
the last session
requires investing in innovation that's
why i've asked the
secretary of energy my energy secretary
jennifer grant home who you saw earlier
to speed the development of critical
technologies to tackle the climate
crisis
no single technology is the answer on
its own
because every sector requires innovation
to meet this moment
you know this critical effort is going
to propel the most impactful
breakthroughs
at home and around the world and lower
the cost
of what we're paying now for polluting
the air so badly
we're going to move to net zero in a
transition in all countries
look every country will need to invest
in
new clean energy technologies as we work
forward
and to deal with net zero emissions
i am also very proud to announce the
united states is again
becoming a key leader in mission
innovation
we helped launch the program during the
obama biden administration
a pact between the world's largest
economies
to ramp up investments in clean energy
research and development
and today america is once again
stepping into the leadership role we
will be joining and a partner
for the nations in efforts to
de-carbonize
critical sectors across the board
including industrial sector where we'll
join with sweden
and india and leadership in the
leadership group for
you know for industry transition the
power sector
where we'll work alongside of the united
kingdom to spread progress and speed it
up toward
a carbon-free power system both here and
around the world
and agriculture the agricultural sector
where we'll launch the agriculture
innovation mission
for climate with the united with united
united arab emirates and other partners
we also i'm very heartened by president
putin's call yesterday for the world to
collaborate
and advance carbon dioxide removal and
the united states looks forward to
working with russia
and other countries in that endeavor it
has great promise
this is a moment for all of us to build
better economies for our children our
grandchildren
and all of us to thrive to thrive in not
just
now but beyond for the next generations
nations that work together to invest in
the cleaner economy
will reap rewards for their citizens the
united states is committed
we are committed to making those
investments to grow our economy
here at home while connecting with
markets around the world
for example we're launching a new global
partnership for climate smart
infrastructure
this will create good-paying jobs here
in america by supporting development of
new clean infrastructure
in our partner countries these are the
sort of partnerships
that are going to be good for all of us
i think they'll have additional benefits
just working together
and today i'm excited to welcome my
counterparts in spain nigeria
vietnam and poland to share their
thinking
on how to realize the economies of the
economic opportunities
of the climate response and we're going
to be joined by
labor and business community leaders
from around the world
talk about what's happening in their
communities around climate-related jobs
and i'm pleased to be joined by
secretary butige's ambassador thai
national climate advisor gina mccarthy
chair of my national climate task force
i look forward to our conversation and
making more progress
more progress throughout the day thank
you mr president what do you think about
the brazilian
[Music]
okay
thank you so much mr president okay
understood
i think it's me right thank you mr
president
it is now my pleasure to introduce the
prime minister of the kingdom of spain
prime minister sanchez the floor is
yours
hello your excellencies distinguished
participants i
i thank president biden for convening
this summit and i sincerely commend
his renewed determination and commitment
to the paris agreement
and multilateralism i fully agree that
this is the only possible way to
overcome what
he defined yesterday as the existential
threat of our time
origin and significant action is needed
to fight the current climate emergency
and the european union including spain
is as one of its climate leaders has
been
consistently working towards that goal
laying the ecological transition will
not help us build back better later
we must use this historical opportunity
to fast forward the transition towards
the neat zero mission future
but also 10 trillion dollars could be
mobilized
globally for kobit 19 recovery the first
signs
are not too encouraging the world is
calling us to act
this week 101 nobel laureates addressed
as they're called to stop causing full
expansion
i would like to reply to them today
spain hears
you loud and clear and we are determined
to act
on it i would like to focus on
how this transition should look like let
me share with you
three messages the first climate action
has to put people at the center
the process of decarbonization will
produce winners and losers
and governments must support proactively
the regions and communities
negatively affected helping transform
challenges into opportunities
investing in climate ambition and just
transition
policies today makes better economy and
social sense
the spanish experience shows that a jews
ecological transition is possible over
the last three years we have closed
our minds and most of our co power
plants
as part of our energy transition
strategy
by 2022 we will have phase out
eight five percent of the installed call
power generation capacity that existed
in 2018. this
outstanding achievement needs to be done
through social dialogue
thanks to engagements with uh with
worker unions business
organizations and local authorities we
carried out
just transition agreements in order to
channel direct investments restore
declining
areas support innovative industrial
projects we train
workers and protect small and medium
enterprises
we're currently working with the
affected regions to attract some of the
most innovative
future-proof projects including
catenates
renewable energy renewable hydrogen or
energy storage matching both the
challenges and the opportunities of this
transition
the second message is that i firmly
believe that the ecological transition
offers extraordinary opportunities
investing in energy transition
technologies can create
close to three times more jobs than the
fossil fuels
for each million dollars spent in my
country spain
the national energy and climate plan
estimates that
more than 230 billion
euros will be mobilized over the next
decade
these private and public investments
will create between
250 thousand and three hundred fifty
thousand jobs
many of them in the manufacturing and
construction sectors
furthermore our new uh kovit recovery
plan
will enable us to mobilize an
unprecedented volume
of money we will benefit from up to 140
billion euros in transfers and loans
over the next
six years and nearly 40 percent of those
funds
will be allocated to ecological
transition related
investments and finally ambitious
climate actions need to to be answered
on a strong regulatory framework this is
why we are just
approving our climate change and energy
transition bill
which enshrines into law the objective
of climate neutrality by 2050
and sends a strong and clear message to
the market
providing legal and certainty ladies and
gentlemen
spain has been little leading by example
we have learned
a lot in the process and we are keen to
share our experience
because we know that addressing climate
change
is a global endeavor we must act
collectively
we must act now and we must not leave
anyone behind i thank you
thank you mr prime minister for sharing
your work on advancing high quality jobs
within your decarbonization strategy
it is now my pleasure to introduce the
president of the federal republic of
nigeria
president buhari welcome
[Music]
government
i would like to express my profound
appreciation
for the president of the united states
his excellency is your budget for
conveniences
at our time the world is experiencing
tremendous vulnerability
from the corona virus pandemic and
climate change impacts among
several other global challenges
the issue of climate change has taken
the front burner
globally as its effects
can be seen and felt all around us
ranging from increased atmospheric
temperature
to irregular rainfall patterns as well
as sea level rise
owing to the melting of glacial
ice nigeria commands
the birding administration was a
positive decision
of returning the united states to the
paris agreement
in addition to bringing about
abundant green economic opportunities
to the united states economy the move
further
complements the larger transition
process
of global economies to low carbon
development pathways
this summit would indeed through
instrumental galvanizing
high level political support with
implementation
of the paris agreement and its
cut wise rule book as well
as inviting more countries and
stakeholders
to take more climate-orientated
responsibilities
as one of the most vulnerable nations
nigeria is undertaking natural
environmentally sound
and climate friendly programs
and trading the past of sustainability
since red fine the paris agreement
in 2006 nigeria has rolled out
several policy enablers
set up institutional frameworks
to cut emission by 20 percent
unconditionally and 45 percent
conditionally with international
support by 2030.
nigeria is convinced that through
net zero transition tremendous
prospects are available for job creation
and other economic benefits
we are expeditiously implementing
programs
that stimulate gradual transition our
transition away from the use of wood
stoves
to kerosene you could find natural gas
bio gas and electricity
the immediate impacts include healthy
competition among private sector players
leading to higher productivity
employment and faster service
delivery
the agricultural production and supply
chain sector we are targeting improved
efficiency
and productivity through the provision
of accurate and timely weather
forecasting
to farmers supply of drought
tolerant and highly mature crop
varieties
and promoting empowerment towards
the diversification of sources
of livelihoods
beyond and in gas flaring by 2030
the oil and gas sector has undertaken
steps
for diversification risk management
systems insurance
agent research and development
and energy crisis learning
the nigerian government in 2017
launched the greenbone program as part
of its commitment
contained in the paris climate agreement
signed
on september 21st 2016.
the overall outcome of the highlighted
actions
have translated into food supply
sufficiency
improved nutrition less hunger
increase employment more jobs
opportunities
better livelihoods reduce poverty
decrease vulnerability to health
challenges
and higher quality of life
excellencies nigeria calls
on countries to embrace circular economy
and sustainable production and
consumption models in order to expedite
attainment of long-term goals of paris
agreement i wish you a excellencies
retreat nigeria's commitment
to galvanize the relevant stakeholders
for climate action
and our readiness to extend support
to regional continental
and global multilateral processes
for the attainment of the left
objectives
of the paris agreement the fight
to redress the impact is the
responsibility
of all thank you
thank you mr president for highlighting
the incorporation of green jobs into the
recovery
from the health and economic crisis in
nigeria
it is now my pleasure to introduce the
president of the socialist republic of
vietnam
president fuch we look forward to your
remarks
the honorable joel biden
president of the united states of
america accents his presence prime
ministers
ladies and gentlemen i thank president
biden for inviting me
and other leaders to this very important
summit i command
the united states return to the paris
agreement
i believe that the renewed leadership
and strong commitment
that president biden exposed during the
opening session
combined with our shared efforts will
lead us on the path towards achieving
the goals of paris agreement
mr president ladies and gentlemen
climate change
is undoubtedly a major existential
crisis for many countries into our
planet
in vietnam last year alone extreme
weather
has taken hundreds of lives and reversed
decades of progress
in poverty reduction
the medical delta our rice bowl
and the home to more than 20 million
vietnamese
is suffering immensely from rising sea
level especially towards the end of this
century
mr president ladies and gentlemen
transitioning to a green
net zero emission economy is an indepe
is an inevitable trend
and imperative to limiting global
warming to 1.5 degrees celsius
this is a challenge but we also bring
about huge opportunities
and benefits including jobs ensuring
energy security
and enhancing economic competitiveness
and sustainability
vietnam resolved to follow this path
at the same time we need a suitable
roadmap
for developing countries much hardship
remains
accordingly i wish to highlight the
following points first
transition must be just and inclusive
it must ensure equal access to
opportunity
benefits place the people the center and
leave no one behind
it must especially be supported by the
people businesses
and scientists communities second
developed countries must
continue to take the lead in emission
reduction commitment while giving
greater concrete support to
developing countries including vietnam
in financing
in new technology development in high
quality and efficient infrastructure
and in job creation we welcome
and hope to receive the assistance from
the u.s international climate finance
plan and
other international financial
arrangements including from
international companies and corporations
third the pursuit of climate goals
should be compatible with each country's
conditions
including the need to alter their
lifestyles their mods
production and their work this endeavor
must be integrated into national
development strategies and plans
each country must itself make efforts
and make good use of international aid
and resources
they need to be national mechanisms for
oversight and evaluation
of implementation to improve the ability
to recover
vietnam is a developing country our
industrialization has only truly begun
three decades ago
yet we make every effort to contribute
to the global action
vietnam have been quick to submit its
ndcs
to the united nations and mainstream
them
into our domestic law for earnest
enforcement
by 2030 we pledge to reduce
emission by nine percent with our
domestic resources
all 27 percent if provided international
support
bilaterally and multilaterally we will
greatly reduce coal based power
generation and increase the share of
renewables
in the total energy primary energy
supply to 20
by 2030 and 30 by 2045
we will reduce greenhouse emission
intensity per gdp
by nearly 15 and methane
emission from agricultural production by
10
earlier this month vietnam launched a
program
to plant a billion trees by 2025
this project alone is expected to absorb
two to three percent of vietnam's total
emission by 2030.
mr president ladies and gentlemen i'm
confident that the challenges of climate
change
shall be drivers for solidarity and
positive change
as we move towards cop26 in the uk and
contribute to a more sustainable future
for generations to come
thank you very much
thank you mr president for sharing your
thoughts on the intersection of
renewable investments in job creation
it is now my pleasure to introduce the
president of the republic of poland
president duda the floor is yours
[Music]
distinguished president biden
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
presidents
prime ministers secretary of state
advisors
first and foremost let me start by
thanking president joe biden for
inviting me to the summit
poland plays a very active role in the
global climate policy
let me just mention that it was a huge
reduction surplus of co2 that we managed
to accomplish
the commitment on the kyoto protocol
from 1997
this surplus was the assumption of six
percent reduction
and in our case we managed to reduce by
as many as 27
because the reduction was 33.
three times poland hosted
uh climate cop conferences
uh in 2018 at cop 24 in katowice we
developed under the polish leadership
the katowice rulebook
as well as the solidarity and just
transition silesia declaration
this paved the way for the adoption of
the paris agreement
and allowed to enhance the importance of
human dimension
in the spirit of the principle that
nobody should be left behind
the momentum given by poland at cop24
has contributed to the european union
becoming the first global economy to
adopt the goal of climate neutrality by
2050 and to further decrease
its emissions by 2030
by at least 55 percent poland
participates in these ambitious efforts
we're also pleased
that a number of states have followed
in the eu's footsteps let me mention
that climate
is the subject to which the three system
initiative that touches great importance
politics part of the 36 states
initiative
like other central europe countries uh
located between the baltic sea the black
sea and the adriatic sea
in recent days i talked to the
presidents of slovenia mr bharat pajar
lithuania
guitars naoceda and bulgaria roman radev
who currently holds the presidency of
the three seas initiative
in the three seas region it is clear to
us that we have to implement an
ambitious climate policy based on the
principles of just transition
taking into account the realities of our
countries and the welfare of our
societies
this is a challenge especially there
where there is a need to conduct deep
economic changes
including the possible closing down of
certain industrial sectors such as coal
sector these are very serious challenges
for states such as poland or bulgaria
climate policy
is going to be the subject of our
discussions uh during our meeting in
july this year
during the summit of three cities in
sofia the capital city of bulgaria
let me stress however that all of us
acknowledge climate goals
set by the european union and all of us
have ambitions to implement them ladies
and gentlemen
by pure political declarations we're not
going to change the reality
that is why poland plans to build a new
zero emission energy system over the
next two decades
thanks to which the share of coal is
going to drop from the current 70
to as little as 11 in 2014.
this is not only an answer to the
agreements
within the european union but first of
all this gives the response to the
expectation as of the new
generation of polls the young generation
this year week i met the youth climate
council
which brings together young
representatives of ngos in poland
who fight for natural environment and
climate protection
they expect the implementation of
ambitious climate goals and at the same
time they are fully aware of the fact
how difficult this road is
and perhaps i'm even more satisfied to
communicate to you ladies and gentlemen
that yesterday
in poland in our country we entered into
an agreement
after a long social dialogue between
minors coal miners and representatives
of the polish government
this agreement respects phasing out call
from the production of electricity
by 2049.
i believe ladies and gentlemen this is a
huge success of the social dialogue that
we've been having in poland
this is also a great and ambitious plan
for the future
if we consider that today call to
produce electricity in poland is about
70 percent
therefore poland will build a
sustainable low emission energy mix
based on nuclear and renewable energy
as well as gas unless we apply all
available technologies the
transformation of our energy system
will simply not be possible polish
u.s agreement on the development of the
polish civil nuclear power program
dated october 2020 confirms our
ambitions
it highlights the importance of
international cooperation
in the field of energy and climate
policy
we should therefore coordinate
international research
and development efforts to create a
critical mess
of affordable technologies innovative
technologies
which are also price affordable we
should also
think how central banks in our countries
can support energy transformation
in line with the principle of
technological neutrality
a climate-friendly transition provides
a huge opportunity also for our citizens
and all sectors of our economy
that is the reason why poland has placed
electric mobility in the center
both in public as well as in individual
transport
it offers a powerful chance to develop
our industry
and to create new jobs already now
we are the biggest exporter of e-buses
in the european union
with a 46 share in the european market
recorded last year
furthermore poland has become a european
leader
in the production of lithium-ion
batteries
we are ambitious also in the sector of
individual transport
and plans to phase out combustion
engines
which i believe will open up a vast
potential for cooperation on both sides
of the atlantic
we also attach considerable importance
to mitigation
polish governmental agency state forests
has implemented
a pilot program of forest sinks carbon
farms
it is a system aimed at using forest
resources
to stimulate the absorption of co2 from
the atmosphere
and to accumulate it within the forest
ecosystem and in wood
products the concept of forest sinks
carbon farms
deserves i believe to be legitimized as
part of international legal order
ladies and gentlemen the pandemic
has brought the world to a halt for a
moment while getting back
on the track of development let's make
sure that this
is not the old track let us build a
synergy between the following three
conventions
convention on climate change on
biological diversity
and to combat desertification let us use
this opportunity to restore the world as
a better
more just more solidarity-based and more
sustainable place
i thank you thank you mr president for
sharing the role of workers in
particular within your decarbonization
strategy
i would now like to recognize my good
friend and colleague the united states
secretary of transportation
pete buda judge thank you thank you
president biden for your leadership on
this
defining issue of our time thank you
ambassador tai for everything that
you're doing in the u.s and
around the world as we've just heard
from these distinguished leaders we are
here to chart new paths forward to
confront the climate crisis
achieving our climate goals will create
new jobs and harness the ingenuity of
our industries
and workers in the u.s the
transportation sector is the biggest
contributor to greenhouse gases
which means that this sector has the
opportunity to be among the biggest
parts of the solution
to climate change the race against
climate change is
not just a question of what will be lost
if we fail
it is about what can be gained if we
succeed
for nations that successfully transition
to a cleaner economy
the result will be jobs and economic
growth
we are certainly recognizing that
potential in the united states
president biden recently introduced the
american jobs plan
it represents a once in a generation
opportunity
to modernize our national infrastructure
so that our economy
and our climate can thrive with its
investments
in electric vehicles public transit
rail road redesign for pedestrians
and sustainable innovative materials
this plan will move us away
from our over reliance on fossil fuels
and toward
net zero carbon emissions this plan is
fundamentally an investment in our
economy
and our collective future it will create
millions of good jobs for the workers
who will make our roads and bridges more
resilient lay new train lines
expand public transit install electric
vehicle chargers
and manufacture the vehicles that will
depend on those chargers
and the majority of these new jobs will
be available to workers without a degree
at least 40 percent of the benefits of
the plan's climate investments will flow
to underserved communities
which often bear the burden of
transportation pollution and
are at high risk of climate disruption
if our planetary warming exceeds 1.5
degrees celsius
the impacts will be catastrophic for all
of us
we still have an opportunity to prevent
that if the depth of our commitment
meets the urgency of this challenge
before us and that is why this gathering
is so important we are all in this
together
pursuing a net zero goal is not a
zero-sum game
we all benefit if we succeed if this
pandemic has taught us anything it's how
interconnected we are and how capable we
are of change
successfully combating climate change
and reaping the full economic benefits
will depend
not only on transportation but on all
sectors
not only on creative ideas but on
workers literally building the future
not only on the choices of any one
nation but on the contributions of
countries
all over the world i thank president
biden
and the leaders here today for meeting
this moment with the urgency and courage
required
let us continue to chart this path
together the benefit of the many peoples
we serve
and the one climate we all share
i'm now pleased to introduce national
climate advisor gina mccarthy who is
helping to coordinate
the all of society approach that you
will hear about in this round table
thank you uh for the introduction
secretary butterjudge and for all of the
work that you're doing
and i'm excited to have a chance to help
moderate an
outstanding panel of entrepreneurs and
business people
so i'll keep my remarks short so we can
dive right in
from the start one of the guiding stars
of our whole of government approach to
climate action has been how we make the
most
of the opportunities that combating
climate change
actually presents to all of us so as we
work to develop our nationally
determined contribution
one of the most important things was
understanding
how it positioned our workers in our
industries
to tackle the climate crisis president
biden has always believed
that tackling the climate crisis
presents an incredible
economic opportunity and the fact is
that creating jobs and
tackling climate change actually can go
hand in hand and it must
and that's why i'm so pleased to be
talking to this group today
because more than anyone else you
understand the opportunities we have
to create good paying union jobs
to improve public health to keep our
community
safe and to advance the issue that is so
important to all of us the issue of
environmental justice
and you're showing that the opportunity
is already here
and it's only going to grow alongside
our ambition
so long as we invest in our
infrastructure
in innovation in our workers and in our
communities
and i'm excited to hear how you are are
already unlocking those opportunities
so let's dive right in to the
conversation
so first let me start with sharon burrow
the general secretary of the
international
trade union confederation sharon you
have
a long history of advocating for workers
around the world
and have led the international trade
union confederation for
over a decade as the global voice for
the world's working people
with over 200 million members in 163
countries
can you please share with us your vision
for what ambitious climate action means
for our global workforce
thank you and it's a pleasure to be with
you
let me congratulate president biden for
the leadership
on climate we really appreciate his
commitment not just to reduce emissions
which is vital but to meet the climate
challenge with jobs
climate-friendly jobs this is central
for a just recovery for the us but also
the foundation of the new social
contract for working people and their
families
everywhere jobs good jobs union jobs
with human and labor rights and living
wages
with the freedom to organize and bargain
collectively
with social protection to support people
in times of crisis that's at the heart
of a just
transition to stabilize the planet
with net zero economies by 2050 we all
know
we have to get at least half of the job
done by 2030
but it cannot repeat past transitions
the
left workers and their communities
stranded
the labor movement fought four and one
global rules for just transition first
in the ilo
and then in the paris agreement these
mean that workers and their unions must
be at the
table as we plan the transition and we
know this means for every sector
the foundation is clean energy but all
technologies must be deployed in
manufacturing transport
agriculture construction services
and of course their supply chains we
know our
cities are a vital part of the equation
and you have so many great mayors
because they accept
responsibility for 40 of emissions
and that the demand and supply
relationships
from those cities can generate
sustainable production and services to
fuel community renewal
with decent work in rural communities in
our own countries
and if global trade is reformed to meet
the same sustainability standards
with human and labor rights and
compliance respected
indeed around the world as a danish
prime minister
said a good example of that right here
right there in the u.s is the framework
agreement between nabtu
and horstead a danish wind company it
will secure
good paying jobs and training for
hundreds of thousands of u.s workers
it's a great example of just transition
in action
europe led by agreements with employers
and unions in germany spain and other
nations
are committed to a green deal with just
transition
underpinned by a social pillar of rights
canada
scotland new zealand south africa kenya
senegal ghana and many others are
amongst
those with examples of agreements or
social dialogue towards a just
transition
that will actually get the job done
this must be the case everywhere if
we're to leave no one behind
but the good news is that for every
dollar or euro
or unit of currency invested in climate
transition there
are jobs 10 jobs in renewable energy
generates 5 to ten jobs
in the supply chains and up to three
times that
in economies where good wages are spent
by those workers and their families and
if the pandemic has taught us
anything it's that we also need
resilience and care
is vital to that health care aged care
child care and education there are even
more jobs here as we build livable
caring communities
we have the technology we have the
finance to get the job done
and if we share it with developing
countries
on top of vital debt relief if every
dollar
of investment has an esg lens
we will re win the race for a just
recovery
and a sustainable future but we need
both ambition and the commitment
on display here to adjust transition
with social dialogue
in all those ndcs as we head towards a
cop
in glasgow this year i leave you with
this
commitment from the union movement there
are no jobs on a dead planet
we will work with everybody to build
good jobs
on a living planet
sharon that was uh in incredible your
passion
is infectious um so next uh
let me uh go to brett isaac the ceo and
co-founder of navajo power
brett navajo natural resources have
powered
and will continue to power the growth of
the american west
this administration is committed to
empowering tribal leaders in our
collective efforts
to tackle the climate crisis so how has
navajo power
envision tribal community-powered
climate solutions
nations have been at the epicenter of
energy impact
and want to continue being the driver of
that effort through the cultivation
of clean energy assets as a developer of
large-scale utility projects naval power
divisions created the opportunity
to take those workforces and economies
that were so
crucial to advancing america's growth
and re-engaging them in a new energy
economy to advance
clean energy growth needed to address
climate impacts
you know we're excited to see president
biden's vision
in engaging our communities and creating
real tangible solutions
to address the climate crisis the notion
that this transition
must be equitable to to those
communities who will be on the edge of
this work
is a large step forward um to
acknowledging the foundation of this
movement
must begin with collaboration you know
tribal nations believe that
you know our role in this is to help
accelerate
you know the advancement of preservation
of our
of our culture of our resources and and
of our
you know our mother earth so the idea
behind what naval power
wants to do is create the platform
that's going to be the spark needed to
accelerate the recovery advancement of
travel
economies you know there's a lot of
workforces that
were built on you know the previous
energy economies that
need this movement in order to advance
and and you know usher in a new era of
energy usage and energy
you know um resiliency and we believe
that
you know navajo power itself can play a
role
in creating that landing spot for job
growth
for economic growth for communities to
thrive
under these conditions that we're
looking to
create with with the development of
large-scale solar
wind storage and all the other
technologies that are yet to be
developed
um that we need in order to get to a
place where we feel like our
our environment is protected and
preserved
and so i you know from from you know
what we see as
as an important step you know we thank
president
biden for kind of convening this
conversation because it's
much overdue but it's much needed in
order for us to advance going forward
so i'm very proud that you know to be
here to talk about what we're doing
but also very proud to get to work under
this uh
administration's initiatives thank you
thanks brett and and i know that tribal
voices remain
so important to us if we want to hope to
lift
all communities in all nations so thank
you very much for those words
um now i'm excited to hear from uh
nutabi sang musia
the ceo of easy solar
great name by the way easy solar um
nutabi the african continent currently
faces
a significant challenge of 600 million
people without access
to a formal grid it's also
has a young and growing population so
what role can renewable energy play in
accelerating both access to energy and
economic livelihoods in africa
so we can ensure that no one is left
behind
thank you so much uh president biden and
dean
mccarthy uh and your administration for
convening this summit and for having me
here
uh as a young african woman i'm
incredibly grateful for this platform
um it's a unique moment in our human
story and i i want to start by taking a
moment to
acknowledge where we find ourselves in
history
up until recent times when any continent
has attempted to bring people into the
modern economy
we've done so without concern for the
planet and its limits
but here today in sub-saharan africa
where 75 percent
of the world's off-grid population lives
we're being asked
not to copy and paste a formula that has
proven effective time and time again
at industrializing and modernizing human
life
we have to raise people out of poverty
we have to give people dignified work
that reduces inequality
all the while not just looking at the
economics but also being
conscious of the climate at the same
time now this may sound like an unfair
conundrum and at times i lament
at the injustice of having to rise above
a problem we did not create
um but i do believe it's a unique
opportunity
to look forward rather than backwards to
challenge the status quo and say
economic development does not have to be
dirty
progress does not have to be recklessly
unjust that we
as africans can learn from the past
while acknowledging what we have
at our disposal in the present i'm
speaking to you here from treetown in in
sierra leone
my company is solar operates in west
africa
our focus countries have some of the
lowest rates of electrification in the
world
when we first started operating five
years ago in syria and liberia it was as
high as 95
of the population without power and i
mean being without power in so many more
ways than one
the vast majority of people who are
off-grid in africa are based in rural
communities
with limited access to economic
opportunities
if current trends continue 100 million
youths
will be entering the african labour
market will be unemployed by 2030.
this is important to me personally
because i'm one of the fortunate
young ones power only went out a few
nights a week in my home when i was
growing up
and i was lucky enough to have access to
economic opportunities
but we cannot let africa's future rest
on luck and good fortune
and thank you thankfully we don't have
to and and here's where my optimism
comes in
busy solo along with many others in
norfolk sector are bringing power to
people
where they are we're going all the way
to the last mile
and doing so by employing people who are
from those communities
in short we're building power from the
ground up
awkward solar companies across africa
and many grids
are already employing as many people as
traditional utility power sectors in
some of the more developed markets in
africa
we heard earlier today from president
kenyatta in kenya decentralized
renewable energy companies
are directly employing upwards of 10 000
former workers
the majority of which are based in rural
areas this figure is comparable to the
number employed by the kenyan state
utilities
and here in west africa easy solar in
just five short years has created job
opportunities for 800
young and passionate people who want to
contribute positively to their
communities
and beyond the direct employment that we
create access to electricity generates
broad economic activity
some estimates put it as high as five
times as many non-energy productive use
jobs
are created through access to
electricity so yes we are at a unique
moment in history but we have so much
more at our disposal now and i think we
can do it differently
we can power communities while providing
access to good work
without the negative impact of carbon
emissions that has
characterized mass electrification in so
many other parts of the world
i haven't spoken about it much but i
want to close off by saying i do believe
there is a role for utility scale power
but we cannot overlook that
decentralized renewable energy is a
major part of the equation
we need firm commitment from government
and the financial community
to deploy the 11 billion dollars in
funding the offered sector needs
to accelerate access to energy and
economic opportunity at scale
we need to mainstream these solutions
that will be a major part of wiping out
energy poverty in africa
while providing a generation of young
people with good work
without harming the planet i hope you'll
join me and the rest of the sector
very excited about what we're doing in
expanding the good work that has already
been done to leave no one behind
thank you so much
nutabi thank you so much i think young
people
everywhere in the u.s and across the
world have made a vast difference
in pointing out the need for urgency
around climate but also bringing such
fresh
energy to the table and ideas you're
right we have to look to the future and
it's yours
and we have to play our part so thank
you for that
now let's turn to george oliver the ceo
of johnson control hi george
it's good to see you george is chairing
the energy and environment committee at
the business roundtable
and he's also leading johnson controls
one of the leading companies
in the sustainable building space george
how do you see the outlook of business
on strong climate action and what role
can buildings play
in tackling the climate crisis
yeah thank you uh ms mccarthy for
leading this great discussion
and thank you mr president uh
distinguished leaders and members of the
cabinet
it is truly an honor to be here today
it is clear from the previous panelists
that there are opportunities in
communities
large and small as we take action on
climate and there is a need for training
to fill the good jobs being created
in my role as chairman and ceo of johns
controls a global leader in smart
healthy and sustainable buildings we're
eager to drive harder and faster
to cut the 40 percent of greenhouse
gases that come from buildings
the good news is that when we do that
the up
that the upgrades pay for themselves
because we are cutting energy waste
i also have the honor of chairing the
business roundtable energy
and environment committee in working
with over 200
of america's largest employers from all
sectors of the economy
i can tell you the ceos recognize the
threats posed by climate change
business roundtable members believe the
risks are real they're increasing
they are costly and they may be
irreversible
as we look ahead to cop 26 in november
we have the chance to implement smart
policies that ensure
that all communities and workers benefit
from reducing carbon emissions
business roundtable believes that a
comprehensive market-based policy
can spur innovations ensure equity
and help avoid the worst impacts of
climate change
importantly business roundtable knows
that business and government
must work together and lead by example
to meet the scope of the challenge
in fact the vast majority of business
roundtable ceos have pledged to reduce
their emissions
with nearly half committing to achieving
net zero emissions in their companies
by 2050 or sooner at johnson control
sustainability
is our business we committed to
achieving net zero carbon before
2040 and announced science-based targets
for 2030.
we are proud to be ranked among the 100
most sustainable companies globally
president biden called for a 4 million
buildings to be revamped absolutely at
john's controls
we know that that can be done and we
would be foolish not to do so because
inefficient buildings
are a climate hazard and because money
is wasted
right along with energy working with our
customers we cut emissions
more than 30 million tons and we have
saved them six billion dollars
and we guarantee the results since we
are confident substantial savings
will be achieved with with digital
technologies
like our open blue platform we are
creating not only efficient
but net zero buildings campuses and
whole
communities so we think it is clear
driving sustainability and tackling
climate change is a collective
effort at the business roundtable and
johnson controls
we know that when we take this challenge
on we will cut emissions
and costs create good jobs and build
resilient
healthy infrastructure mr president we
are ready to get to work
thank you
well george thank you um it's incredible
to have
the business roundtable and your voice
so powerfully
partnering on this issue with us and it
means a lot as well as your leadership
at johnson controls it's
uh it's quite inspirational um
next let's hear from roxanne brown hi
roxy
it's good to see you the uh roxanne is
the international vice president of the
united steelworkers
uh the united steelworkers represent
almost a million american workers in
manufacturing and transportation and
buildings
and many other critical parts of our
economy
roxy what can governments around the
world do to ensure that we put workers
right square at the center of our
transition to clean
infrastructure thank you so much for the
question
gina and it's so great to see you and
also great to see you as well president
biden
it's an honor to join this summit on
behalf of the 850 000 members of the
united states workers union in the u.s
and canada
and we really commend the biden harris
administration for
actively seeking out the voice of labor
in this really important discussion and
i would say
that is the first part of my answer
governments
around the world can ensure that workers
are at the center of a clean energy
infrastructure by simply making room for
us at the table
like you did today oftentimes policy
makers form
ideas about what they think is essential
for workers in a particular state
industry region province or country but
really only workers can best answer the
question of
how a net zero economy includes us
and i urge leaders around the world to
engage in earnest and honest
conversations with workers
and unions as policies are being formed
and to understand that workers are key
allies and shaping and moving policy and
should not be an afterthought
in your question gina you mentioned the
various sectors usw members
are employed in from the steel plate our
members at cleveland cliffs and gary
indiana make
to the fiber optic cables our members at
corning in wilmington north carolina
make to the pro terra electric buses our
members in los angeles california make
to the water system distribution
services our members at american water
and kokomo indiana provide
to the copper our members at rio tinto
and magna utah
mine usw members literally
supply america every day with the
components
energy critical materials and services
for our nation's physical
and social infrastructure and we
recently kicked off a campaign
called we supply america to highlight
the important role our members play
they're proud to do this work
their families depend on the good family
sustaining union wages and benefits
attached to these jobs and communities
all across this country
depend on the tax base those jobs
provide to help fund our schools
and libraries we must strengthen our
domestic manufacturing base and support
its critical workforce
here at home to manufacture the next
generation of these technologies
in addition to expanding and sourcing
from
the domestic supply chain right here
with the right policies we can
incentivize industry to
decarbonize and maximize energy
efficiency
by investing in technologies like carbon
capture
direct air capture renewable biomass and
combined heat and power
these are all ways to ensure that
workers
will be at the center of u.s clean
energy infrastructure
and you know i have to say we strongly
agree president biden
that the american jobs plan is a once in
a generation
transformational type of investment
we are ready to help pass policies
like the protecting the right to
organize act that will help make
the new jobs of the clean energy economy
family and community sustaining union
jobs
we are ready to support you in helping
advance and revitalize existing
industries
putting workers at the center of those
solutions
and build an even stronger manufacturing
and energy base for generations to come
our sleeves are rolled up mine are you
just can't see them
our boots are on the ground and we are
ready to go
thank you so much thank you
sister roxy never fails to supply the
right words at the right time and
thank you so much union not labor union
union there you go um i want to just
uh say that that these unions have
not just a place at the table but we're
listening and
uh and president biden is being making
sure of that so thank you so much roxy
uh let's turn now to erica mackey the
ceo of grid
alternatives erica i had the privilege
of attending
two grid alternative solar installations
in fact you had me on the roof
on both of those occasions and i talked
to the job trainees learning solar
schools while
solar skills while they were installing
solar and low-income communities and
communities of color
in los angeles and washington d.c so how
does grid alternatives
work illustrate how clean energy
can be beneficial to all individuals
and families in every community
thank you national climate advisor
mccarthy you were awesome on a rooftop
president biden secretary kerry
dignitaries thank you for having me
grid alternative's mission is to build
community-powered solutions to advance
economic and environmental justice
through renewable energy
for the past 20 years grid alternatives
the nation's largest non-profit solar
installer
has been working with communities most
impacted
by economic and climate injustices to
bring the benefits of clean energy and
jobs
to all families and individuals we will
not
achieve a renewable energy future
without addressing the systemic
injustices
that have disproportionately impacted
people of color
the benefits of renewable energy between
air
long lasting careers lower energy bills
must not be limited to the privileged
yet
low-income communities and communities
color are usually left out of the
conversations about our clean energy
future
and i applaud the administration for the
environmental justice council
grid alternatives works coast to coast
to push for policies
that make solar energy and cutting-edge
clean technologies
available to everyone by creating
strong policy solutions that center the
leadership of economic and environmental
justice communities
we can sure ensure everyone benefits
now and for generations to come clean
energy can be transformative
for the people the planet and the
economy
a growing solar energy industry needs
skilled workers
at all levels solar jobs are meaningful
and pay well
with grid alternatives hands-on training
individuals learn
solar skills while participating in
real-world solar installations
we make training opportunities
accessible to groups that are
traditionally underrepresented in solar
including women people of color those
impacted by the criminal justice system
our graduates jump start lifelong
careers
connecting with employers or starting
their own successful business ventures
clean energy together with energy
storage electrification
and other technologies is necessary for
both
climate mitigation and climate
adaptation
while replacing polluting energy sources
clean energy investments
also benefit health clean energy makes
us more resilient
to the increasingly common disasters
brought on by the climate crisis
families depend on electricity for
medical equipment and food
when the power goes out local solar and
storage can save lives
families harmed most by fossil fuel
pollution
and climate destruction also pay more of
their incomes
for the very energy systems causing
those harms
another source of economic instability
those most impacted by fossil fuel
pollution climate-induced disasters and
burdensome energy costs
must be first from climate solutions
they must benefit first not as an
afterthought
energy agency and ownership must and can
be
put in the hands of communities through
clean energy
transition we need to include everyone
in climate solutions
we need climate justice grid
alternatives envisions a rapid
equitable transition to a world powered
by renewable energy
that benefits everyone our experience on
the ground
shows that this critical opportunity is
possible
with collective effort
erica thank you very much uh i know grid
alternatives
always reminds us that uh clean energy
is not a
a luxury for a few it's a necessity for
all of us
and thank you for advancing that uh now
let's hear from jack allen the ceo
of proterra who i'm sure the president
remembers was gracious enough to
virtually host him
just a few days ago jack proterra
manufactures
half of the u.s electric bus market
which is pretty amazing and as you know
funding for electric school buses
is a priority in the american jobs plan
you know electrifying a bus fleet is
good for the planet good for community
health and good for jobs
so what role do you see the federal
government playing
in spurring the demand for zero emission
electric vehicles
including school buses before you talk
jack i want to thank you for
spending some time with me and i told
you i used to drive a school bus
i want to drive on your electric school
buses okay
i got a license i used to have my anyway
okay that would be that would be just
great mr president
and uh thank you uh national climate
advisor mccarthy of course
uh mr president from all of us at potera
having the opportunity to be with you
twice in one week is quite incredible so
uh thank you all very much now protara
is grateful for the government's
long-standing
support of electric transit buses and
zero emission
transportation we delivered our first
electric transit bus over a decade ago
to foothill transit
with the support of funding from the
2009 recovery act
the building on these early deployments
the federal government increased support
for zero emission electric
transportation through programs
like the federal transit
administration's low
and no emission vehicle program the lono
provides
funding to state and local governments
to acquire zero emission transit buses
and has been responsible for funding
hundreds of electric transit buses
across the nation from
juneau alaska to miami florida it really
wasn't that long ago that the questions
many were asking was whether the transit
market would even move towards
electrification
well that question has been answered
thanks to the help of the federal
government
this transition is well underway since
cortera's initial development
over a decade ago we've sold 1 000
electric transit buses
so where do we go now well there's an
opportunity for the federal government
to go even further
by spurring increased demand for
commercial electric vehicles
for infrastructure and to deepen the
supply base
in the united states school buses as you
mentioned
you know they're a great example and one
of the most exciting applications
for electric vehicle technology
switching to electric school buses
means cleaner air for our children and
our grandchildren to breathe
and a healthier planet for them to enjoy
yet today unlike transit buses school
buses do not receive the same level of
federal funding for electrification
so federal programs like lono can help
serve as a roadmap
to accelerate the electrification of
other commercial vehicles
such as electric school buses and
delivery vehicles
one of the lessons that we've learned
over a decade of delivering electric
buses
is the critical role that charging and
infrastructure plays in electrification
our customers have told us they would
like to go faster towards
electrification
charging remains a barrier to ev
adoption now private enterprises had to
solve this challenge
and we will but it is well worthy of
strong support from the federal
government
to prepare the nation for our clean
transportation future
this includes convening public partner
public-private partnerships on charging
infrastructure between the government
companies like bertera the fine union
organizations that are represented at
the summit
and electric utilities nationwide
collectively
we can do this electric vehicle
technology is an opportunity
for the united states to be at the
leading edge
of the innovations that will create good
american jobs
will modernize our nation's
infrastructure and help to build a more
just
and resilient economy with over 600
employees nationwide
including as roxanne said many
represented by the united steelworkers
we've experienced first-hand influential
we believe the technologies
that we need to meet global demand for
zero emission transportation
can and must be built right here in the
united states
including cell manufacturing
thank you for the opportunity to be with
you today what a wonderful thrill for
all of us
thank you thank you
george thank you thank you for uh for
uh uh all of your commitment to
to our kids um and to our cities and
making
the air cleaner as a grandmother of
three young kids i very much
appreciate it so thank you for that and
i think mr president as you know your
american jobs plan is going to go all
in on building the charging
infrastructure that we need
that's going to allow george to expand
his business and
all of us to the guy's going to build
what we're about to hear from
all right let's let's move on because uh
uh
i'll tell you that uh we want to talk to
um
lonnie stevenson right now uh lonnie is
the
uh the president of the international
brotherhood of electric workers and
and he is uh he is last but certainly
not least because he's a major player
um in looking at how we can actually
build his union um with almost eight
hundred
000 skill members across the wide
variety of fields they will
build our country moving forward as well
lonnie what do energy workers need to
see
in order to feel really confident that
they will not be left behind
in a transition to cleaner power
generation
well thank you advisor mccarthy and
thank you mr president
and thank you for your invitation and
thank you for hosting this event today
this is such a critical question have
you made clear again and again
fighting climate change isn't just about
cutting carbon emissions
but creating good jobs and creating good
jobs
means above all creating union jobs
as the president of the largest energy
union in all of north america
my members work in every sector that's
out there
from coal and gas to wind and solar
from nuclear and power transmission and
delivery
these are good union jobs jobs that are
the foundation
of a strong middle class and healthy
communities it's folks like my members
that are leading the clean power
revolution
keeping them at the center of the clean
energy industry requires lawmakers and
regulators
to take some key steps first
we must tie all federal clean energy
investments
from direct infrastructure spending to
tax credits
to strong labor protections
protections like prevailing wage laws
which promote
higher incomes safer work sites and
increase
productivity protections like
buy american provisions that make sure
the push for zero carbon energy
results in more domestic and
manufacturing jobs
such as those that would be created by
the production of halo fuels
that are needed for the next generation
of nuclear reactors
mr president i know that you've laid out
an
ambiguous plan to build a massive
network
of electric vehicle charging stations
with journey level electricians who are
certified
by the electric vehicle infrastructure
training program
that means hundreds of thousands of good
new union construction and manufacturing
jobs
and protections like stronger collective
bargaining rights
that give all energy workers the right
to freely
join a union many existing
energy jobs are good jobs for one reason
and that's because they are union jobs
but the truth is
not enough solar wind and other
renewable power or
power are union jobs that's why passing
the pro act
is so important this legislation would
make it easier for workers to exercise
their right to join a union of their
choice
and harder for the employers to
interfere with that right
i know that you support that mr
president and i hope the u.s senate
will move on it soon we also
need local hire requirements it's tied
to all projects that receive federal
investment
these provisions increase racial and
gender diversity
in the energy and construction workforce
they open the doors to good paying union
careers
and secure the jobs go to those who need
them the most
bringing a measure of environmental
justice to communities that have been
have paid too high a price through
pollution
and discrimination and now suffer from
years of disinvestment
finally as important as solar and wind
are
we must invest in all forms of
carbon-free energy technologies
such as carbon capture hydrogen and
nuclear
this isn't just good for the environment
it's good for the economy
and for jobs as well for example
ibew members operate or maintain over 90
percent
of the u.s nuclear fleet and nuclear
power plant operators
are among the highest hourly wages in
the united states
that's the power of a union contract
we also need to support building out a
modern grid
that means doubling the transmission
capacity
that means smarter neighborhood
distribution systems
all interconnected by 21st century
network of fiber optics
and that can double as a country's
consumer broadband net network
that's not only the backbone of a clean
economy
it's a surefire way to create more
skilled
union jobs the current energy transition
can be a win for the climate and a win
for jobs
as long as lawmakers commit to
implementing labor protections
that ensure new energy jobs are good
union jobs
this is a once in a lifetime opportunity
to build our economy back
better and the men and women of the ibaw
are ready to get working in our nation
we can
move into the clean energy future thank
you again
for the opportunity thank you line
thank you so much lonnie and um i know
that between you and your 800
000 skill members we are going to make
it in america so
i'm very excited and mr president i'm
sure you'll agree this was an incredible
panel
and i want to thank everybody for your
passion your inspiration
and your willingness to tell us that
that the future is ours if we want to
grab it
and we are going to do just that so let
me turn it over now to ambassador tai
and again thank you for everyone for
your terrific words
well thank you so much i would like to
thank president biden
prime minister sanchez president buhari
president fooke president duda my
colleagues here secretary budej
advisor mccarthy and all of our
panelists today for
the thoughtful and inspiring program
that we've just been a part of this
week's summit
underscores the reality that our time
to tackle the climate crisis is now
today's speakers have shown that taking
meaningful steps
to combat climate change can be
a powerful driver of economic
opportunity
good paying jobs and positive global
competition
as the united states trade
representative my work
lies at the intersection of domestic
and international economic policy
i know that care and maintenance of our
planet's environmental conditions
are critical to our economic viability
and our potential for shared prosperity
as we say necessity is the mother
of invention the need to act on climate
requires significant change and it is
already
sparking innovation and opportunity
we can build on these beginnings towards
a future
that is cleaner and brighter with new
market opportunities
and high-paying quality jobs
and we must do so in a way that advances
equity
for underserved and marginalized
communities
as countries around the world determine
their domestic measures
for decarbonization environmental
conservation
and clean energy trade policy can be a
powerful tool
to create the incentives for for
positive competition
and a race to the top in realizing
our collective prosperity historic
approaches
and new initiatives like those discussed
today and the proposals
included in the american jobs plan the
empowering people
clean energy initiative and plans for
zero emissions transportation
and transshipment all of these clearly
demonstrate that innovative and dynamic
solutions are within our reach
most importantly today's discussion
offers us hope
ideas and an invitation to join
forces to do our part realize
the goal of transitioning to net zero by
2050
in order to preserve and protect our
planet and create
economic opportunities for our children
and their children now it is my pleasure
to turn to special envoy carrie for some
final thoughts
before you go john i add one thing to
this
panel i may you know uh
every once in a while you
are confronted as a government official
a business leader a labor leader
with a real problem and it doesn't take
you long to figure out
that how to turn it into an opportunity
one thing john everybody talked about
today
was is there anything else you can think
of
that could create as many good jobs
going in the middle of the 21st century
let me think about it
what else could there be that would have
the opportunity
to create so many
jobs while doing so much good
every single one of you the business
leaders
labor leaders foreign leaders lit
foreign foreign leaders of
other parts of the world every one of
you
you talked about this in terms of jobs
it's astounding
and i think this is part of that sort of
fourth industrial revolution here
this is this is an opportunity to in the
process
this time of doing
the right thing and creating jobs of
actually bringing our countries
closer together because
it is in our interest just like and my
excuse the colloquial reference but my
mother would always say when something
very bad would happen
in our family out of everything bad joe
something good will come if you look
hard enough for it
well we're seeing that with the
god-awful crisis where we lost millions
of people
to covet 19 to see the collaboration we
never had before that i have
i've been doing this a long long time
and
it makes us realize that you can't build
a wall high enough
to be able to keep out whatever that
next virus is you have to take care of
the virus
where it originates no matter how small
the country no matter wealthy no matter
how poor it is
and i know that's why for example we're
working like the devil to get to a point
we can export
export of vaccines
but think of this as well every one of
you the last two days
have talked about the need for us to
collaborate
i found it fascinating that and i happen
to agree with them that
you know president putin and i have our
disagreements
but he's talking about how you capture
carbon from space
you've john you and i have talked about
that the whole notion
that it makes overwhelming sense as much
as the president
of russia and i disagree that two big
nations can cooperate
to get something done and this time get
something done that benefits everybody
it's not like we're arguing whether or
not one
nation is going to get be better
benefited or
worse and impacted by what we do
and so i just think that if we can keep
the focus
on the jobs we're going to create the
economic opportunity the growth
and for and and in my country at least
on union jobs to provide the ability to
raise
the economy raise their gdp raise
every part of who we are i think i think
this is
just an incredible incredible
opportunity
incredible opportunity i've been working
with the business roundtable which is
you know the idea the business
roundtable the afl-cio
working together when i came to politics
years ago was
non-existent almost but we see
the opportunities i hope we don't lose
lose focus here
lose a sense of how much we can do
together by helping ourselves
we're helping ourselves we're helping
others this in this in this endeavor
it really is important and and uh i just
want to say
uh one thing to uh bird in the navajo
nation
let my wife come home she likes the
navajo nation too much she keeps being
out there she's out there for two days
she was out there
before i don't know you know what i mean
i called her i said where i said
i'm staying another day so you know let
her come home okay
i don't want to you know that's too far
for me to commute
i i shouldn't be so but hey look this
is this is about what we can do together
and i
i'd be remiss if i didn't say i don't
consider
you all you're giving me a lot of credit
for convening this
uh i wouldn't have convened this had i
not had the overwhelming
help support and initiative from former
secretary kerry my good friend
this is he feels this in his bones this
is to him something that is
consequential
and he knows a lot about it so you're
not gonna
you're gonna continue to see a lot of
all of us here but anyway i just want to
thank you john before you
this panel got shut out because i uh
and by the way first person i went i got
in trouble because was biden really
going to do something about the
environment
first person i went to was talani
stevens in ibw
because i'm so sick and tired of people
talking about how we get this done and
don't care about jobs
and it was lonnie stepped up and labor
stepped up
and business is stepping up so i want to
thank you okay
sorry john for being so colloquial but
thank
thank you thank you for your personal
comments but more importantly uh
uh thank you for your leadership because
we wouldn't be here
without you having had the courage and
the readiness to take this
on and tackle tough issues um
if i may just want to thank ambassador
thai and i want to thank secretary
butter judge and
my cohort my colleague from
massachusetts gina
mccarthy mr president um
it is your vision that set out to
convene
this summit not a hundred days into your
presidency
and i want to thank you for
demonstrating your deep commitment to
action
uh for bringing together so many
essential voices that have been as
articulate as any i've ever heard
uh all of whom want to do the same
and they all understand as you have said
mr president
this decade these next 10 years are the
critical years
the scientists have told us
unequivocally
that we have about 10 years now to make
the critical decisions and
implement them that will avoid the worst
consequences of the climate crisis you
said this
and that's why we're here this has to be
the decade of decision
this is the period of time why because
only if we reduce sufficiently in this
decade
can we keep alive the vision of 1.5
degrees
and can we achieve 2050 net zero
so uh mr president as we approach the
end of uh of this summit this leaders
summit on climate
uh let me again thank all of the leaders
uh and participants who have joined us
over the past few days
as well as those who are tuning in at
home and all over the world we're deeply
appreciative
we're very very grateful uh for your
partnership
all of you all of the countries
represented here
uh we are going to continue these
conversations over the course of the
next months
we have six months plus to glasgow
and as president biden has said and i
can affirm
again and again and many of you have
said to me
glasgow is the last best hope we have
to galvanize the world to move in this
direction and get the job done
and what president biden and all the
rest of us hope this summit is done
is shown particularly in these last two
panels
this is a plus this is an economic
bonanza
this is an opportunity to have the
greatest
beneficial economic transformation since
the industrial revolution
and we've learned a lot since then so
we will continue on the road to glasgow
at the direction of president biden
mr president well john thank you as we
close
this historic summit i want to take a
moment to thank the world leaders
and all the participants from around the
globe whoever
joined together to confront the
existential threat
of climate change there's no threat like
it
over the last two days i think we made
some important progress
and the spirit of increasing efforts to
address climate change globally
we're launching an initiative to help
developing countries
strengthen their climate efforts while
achieving their development
goals and that's going to mean money
yesterday i announced the united states
made a new commitment under the paris
agreement to cut
our emissions by 50 to 52 by the end of
this decade
and we'll get there by investing in
american workers american jobs american
infrastructure
and building a stronger and more
resilient economy
we also welcome ambitious targets
announced this week by
two great partners my good friend uh the
prime minister of japan
prime minister suga announced that japan
will cut emissions by up to 60
upper human 50 below the 2013 levels
almost doubling their current target
prime minister trudeau another good
friend from canada
will reduce emissions by as much as 45
below the 2005 levels
these announcements came on top of a
demonstrated leadership
and strong existing targets set by the
european union
and the united kingdom together these
commitments mean that
half of the world's economy is now
committed
to to pace the action that we need
at a pace we need to limit warming to
1.5 degrees
an amount beyond which scientists tell
us if we said a thousand times
all of us could be at a point of no
return
we also heard encouraging news
announcements from
argentina brazil south africa and south
korea
and i'm looking forward to working with
india's prime minister modi in a
new partnership to achieve our climate
and energy goals making this
a core pillar of our bilateral
cooperation
and the commitments we've made must
become
real commitment without us doing that
it's just a lot of hot air no pun
intended
you know we must implement these
commitments
accelerate them and innovate and invest
in order to reach them
and we need to work together once again
to build a clean energy future that
delivers good jobs
and overcomes the threat of climate
change investing in innovation
and on our people raising our ambitions
ensuring every nation does its part
and we'll meet again in glasgow in
november
for the u.n climate conference i believe
we're going to meet those moments
i think we're going to meet the moment
that we've all been talking to make this
commitment
and to keep the commitment it's an
economic imperative
i think it's a moral imperative to
future generations
here in america there's never been a
challenge we couldn't meet
if we put our minds through it and did
it together
i hope your countries feel the same way
i know we can do this
i know we can do this thank you for your
commitment
thank you for joining the summit and
thank you for stepping up
to confront this crisis before it's too
late
i know we can seize the opportunities of
a cleaner
stronger and more resilient economy and
deliver the benefits
to people in each and each of our
nations
so i look forward i look forward to
working alongside
you to confront the climate crisis
to build a better world for all of our
children and grandchildren
we're going to do this together thank
you all and may god bless you and let's
get to work
thanks again
thanks everybody
we know the kind of world we want
healthier
safer more sustainable
equitable where nature thrives
communities are healthy and
opportunities
are plentiful we know
we can create this world the challenge
is profound
and we must move faster than ever before
but the world is ready for action
we can limit climate change
with a singularity of purpose
every nation united in commitment
ready to measure success with progress
not promises
and ensure that when the story of our
time is written
we will have met this moment we
can do this we must do this and we will
do this
the time for action
[Music]
is now
[Music]
you